my mind was drawn attention to the
economists last week which described
Jacob Riis Marg as a neo Victorian
backbench novelty however I'll leave
that thought with you as we get on to
the more serious business by simply
quoting from a magazine counter Atkinson
welcome to the cabinet meeting item 1
apologies for absence from councilor
organ and from council house right ok
the disclosures of interest for items
that are not here no none mine yes just
seeing Council richest walking we are
Corot aren't we councillor Pemberton is
here but he's busy
now we had a lengthy meeting with the
parish council this morning and he's
gone off to see mr. week so he won't be
here either right minutes confirmed and
signed the minutes of the meeting held
on the 15th of January they were
circulated as a notice of decision are
you happy though sign these as a true
record of that meeting I must add the
parking standards minute has been
modified by me using my statutory powers
but that's only for some extras which we
will come to another time and another
place but the essence of the cabinet
decision has been retained right item 4
I presume is item 4 my paperwork doesn't
say so what would happen there Caroline
however revenue and capital budget 2018
to 2019 we have some additional papers
we have a supplementary paper this
contains four documents which are quite
important one is the local government
finance settlement that gave us in round
figures an extra 60,000 pounds next year
probably even beyond next year that we
hadn't anticipated usually those of us
that are familiar with it you get a
provisional settlement sometime about
the beginning of December or the middle
of December depending on when they can
actually get round to giving it to us
and our papers for the transitional of
the consultation papers for the budget
which were done at the last cabinet
meetings are based on those figures but
sooner or later the government get
around to actually finalizing the
settlement and that's basically it so we
have got an extra six
two thousand pounds and this meeting
will determine probably what to do with
that appendix - in the additional papers
which are off before us the budget task
and finish group this is a group set up
by the scrutiny committee and the
scrutiny committee have a look at things
and consider alternative proposals and
you'll see in there that the cabinet
budget proposals have been declared a
sound but there were also alternative
proposals submitted by the Liberal
Democrats and those we will consider
later on in this item and there seems to
be loads of pages about them good grief
appendix 3 non-domestic rate payers
consultative panel that is a meeting
that we hold with the business
ratepayers
it's been our statutory duty to do it
for some time and we this year was no
exception we had very few business
ratepayers come to see us but when you
look at the paperwork that we've seen
our budget is becoming increasingly
dependent on a top-up from the business
rates pool and indeed those figures and
that top-up have been around in the
papers that mr. Buckland has prepared
for us and then appendix 4 will be the
medium term financial plan as it stands
right now it might be different if we
amend the budget at this particular
meeting so consequently those documents
are valid on top of that I have
circulated this piece of paper with
yellow stripes on it which came out of
the documentation that we were sent for
the proposals to highlight the Lib Dem
proposals
finally we have an appendix hey I don't
know quite what was wrong with annex one
gentle surely it should be appendix five
it should be pendants one appendix one -
what appendix lump that paper it was
already right right sorry this has only
got appendix two three and four it
should be called appendix one
I should have deferred to mr. buckle and
without arguing with him obviously and
these are the results of the survey work
that was done that we did that was
undertaken by Simon / field and this
gives us some clues as to what we should
actually spend our money on and indeed
you'll notice on page five of Appendix
one that the top four items CCTV and
crime reduction somebody had an idea a
few years ago that we could actually
withdraw from that but perhaps not we
won't be doing that housing most
important street cleaning most important
and public convenience is another case
where we had proposals put before us to
close them all down but kept them open
and that was obviously the right
decision and this popular with the
public or those that respond so
basically we have all these issues put
before us and they are part of our
discussion now the budget he's otherwise
not dissimilar to the one that we put
out for consultation and there are a lot
of information in the budget report
about first of all the capital program
capital program is not particularly
outrageous it's one of those things that
we have put forward with the usual
stodgy things that we have to actually
spend our money on
so recommendation one is the council
because we're making these
recommendations to council approves that
proposed medium-term number two cabinet
approves the proposals for fees and
charges detailed at appendix five or a
suitable amended version if you want we
can start messing about with fees and
charges I'm rather hoping that you won't
do right because these have been in the
they were all except for the planning
fees which we didn't know about at the
time we knew they were going to change
but we didn't have the detail but the
latest soar the up-to-date planning fees
are now included in this document this
is something we don't send it to Council
this is something that has the approval
of cabinet the medium-term revenue
budget is the important issue and that
is vitally important because that looks
at all the changes that we're proposing
the administration has proposed certain
changes I won't go through them now
because I haven't committed them to
memory and B they're all in the
documentation which we can read and I
don't think anybody or any member of the
cabinet has an issue with the proposed
expenditure then four and five four is
the cabinet approves the non-domestic
rates provisional contributions blah
blah blah this is a document that we
have to ask Council to approve although
we haven't got a clue how to amend it
and we have to rely on the professional
expertise of our finance team to produce
it well we can have is that number five
the level of council tax is 137 Parros
for a bandy property what that means is
that the proportions for the other bands
which are set by law will be appropriate
and that represents a one percent
increase over this year so what we have
is the budget that went out for
consultation I I know there's a proposal
coming up for an amendment any minute if
not more than one we have the proposals
of the Liberal Democrats and we have
effectively a sound budget and
everything even with those modifications
can be done we've also had a paper from
mr. Buckland saying that we did discuss
at some time whether or not we should
spend more of our reserves on certain
issues but that's not deemed as this
afternoon to be part of the budget
setting process we will discuss those
proposals where I have had a
confidential paper from mr. Buckland
which makes sound reading on how we
should effectively spend some of our
reserves and we can refer to this in the
budget debate at full council which is
two weeks today okay so over to you
chaps castle riches thank you chair a
small amendment if I can as some of you
know I've got quite an understanding of
how broadband works in particular
wireless broadband one of the issues
that we've got with the rollout of
high-speed broadband through the
district is that it's there are certain
areas of the district which are almost
certainly will never get or it doesn't
work well yeah we just won't work it
doesn't work as well it doesn't work as
well yeah so so the the brief background
information in is that running in fiber
lines and copper lines is an order of
magnitude more expensive than wireless
transmission wireless transmission is
becoming more and more popular you start
to see these lollipops popping up at
this idea housing estates as they're
building them that's what it's designed
for
so we've got a situation where some of
the rural extremities of the district
will almost certainly not get high-speed
broadband as a result of the the rollout
that were involved in largely to do with
the rural nature of the district and how
expensive it is to run those copper and
fiber lines out to the extremities
broadband is a utility now it is I think
as important as a telephone line it is
important for some people as electricity
certainly for businesses that are
working from home and so on so my
proposal is that we set aside 50,000
pounds with the budget to look at how
wireless broadband can be provided to
these it's these far extremities there's
a couple of things first of all if you
look at there are examples of this
already functioning through the district
so as far as I'm aware older Minister is
almost entirely serviced by the old
secure state with wireless broadband
because they're never going to get fiber
broadband and 50,000 pounds doesn't seem
like an awful lot of money in comparison
to the commitment we make through BD UK
however I can assure you from a
technical perspective Wireless
implementation is an order of magnitude
less expensive than cabled
implementation so 50,000 pound will go a
long way in discovering areas of the
district that we can provide with
high-speed broadband and in some cases
it may well facilitate it I think this
will pave the way for a wider discussion
about allocating more money and larger
tranches of money towards the wireless
provision thank you right councillor
Richard
Thank You chair and I'd second what
authorities has put forward if I may
also put my own amendment forward as
well as you know in May last year we
announced the number of priority
projects for this council to support one
of which was the regeneration of priori
square in Studley we continue to have
very positive conversations with the
site owners the coop and I would hope
that we will be able to continue that
into a successful solution for the site
however it has gone on for
sometime we've been searching for
something certainly for one decade I've
been alluded to two decades this morning
so I think we need to make a statement
to attend intent and I would support or
I would like to put put the proposal
forward that we allocate fifty thousand
pounds towards the preparation of ACPO
of the site if nothing else is show
intent to cover we are serious about
this and we expect a solution imminent
thank you right councillor Jefferson I
would second counselor Richards proposal
I mean this is dragged down long long
enough and I think putting that money in
the big budget sends a clear signal
councillor Morse apologies can I just
support councillor Richards is obviously
you're reading our papers we concede
that that was a proposal from the
Liberal Democrats which we are
supporting councilor kettle I'm going
back to council Rich's proposal as you
know at the OSC has been trying to work
with BT UK to understand the level of
rollout across the district it is
remarkably different disappointing that
for the second time be the UK have been
unable to provide basic operational
information as to how well they're doing
in this district and I think I have the
conversation somebody they appear to be
driving forward by using the rearview
mirror currently we have
nearly 7,000 properties at the end of
the current phrase who will not be
covered but they're unable to identify
to us where those 7,000 properties
appear to be as a result of which within
my own ward an uncovered property has
set up a meeting with a local
the National actually Wireless supplier
who is proposing settlement network
within my ward at no cost to the
individuals concerned and I have put
that individual in touch with mr. Platts
on my right with a view to saying what
could be done going forward because this
company has worked with four of them
five of the local authorities already
providing coverage at no cost local
authority and I have no commercial
connection to this company I hasten to
add
but BD UK do not deserve from their
performance to date in front of us to
receive a penny more of our money until
they demonstrate that they are treating
rural Stratford properly currently the
number of uncovered properties in work
show as I said is just under seven
thousand the number of uncovered
properties in Warwick rugby Nuneaton bed
Worth and north work for districts is
just just over eight thousand so
Stratford is being appalling we badly
serviced by BD UK in comparison to the
four other district comes within within
Orange County therefore whilst I
completely support mr. Richards proposal
that we should allocate funding towards
the rollout of wireless broadband I
think that money should be coming out of
the budget that we've set aside spent a
beedi you care because they're not going
to deliver what we're expecting why are
we paying them any money at all can I
answer that point if we have through
various decision making of this council
committed a certain amount of money to
be paid to be the UK that's paid through
the County Council so they will call on
our funds then turn handed
to be the UK I don't think we can
suddenly make a decision today or now to
redirect that funding in some other area
because you feel that there needs to be
a penalty on them for their performance
I agree with you that their performance
I'm sorry that's what you were saying
but they I agree with you that then you
say mister but when you pay for service
you expect to get a service when as I've
demonstrated from their figures the
quality of our coverage is about four
times worse than other districts in Mora
County Council I believe we're not
getting that service yeah therefore they
need to demonstrate to us why we should
be paying for something we're not
getting well that may be the case but
what I'm saying is that having allocated
that money to County Council or
internally responsible for paying to be
the UK I think we could get ourselves in
a tricky water and I think having extra
money like the grant settlement another
60,000 pounds that we got last week we
are proposing or I think counts the
riches is proposing that we spend that
amount of money on these units whereby
we don't connect to the main broadband
at all we work through independent relay
stations like they have it always cut
Park like I discovered recently they
have in blockly in Gloucestershire and I
discovered that quite by accident by
talking to somebody on a local business
on a train back from London when
suddenly we found ourselves sat around
the same table and the same seats and
got into conversation with someone who's
quite well known to us in this council
and who communicates quite when I
discovered that they've got that in a
village in Gloucestershire just across
the border whereby there are huge
problems they were they
um we have we have it above the village
of Edgehill it already unfortunately at
the moment it doesn't cover quite a
large proportion look to the shadow of
the hills so it's mechanically already
been done that was confirmed when we had
presentation at the scrutiny committee
recently and I know you were there
I came in at the back of the room and
the effectively was appalled by the
revelation of this district has been so
badly treated and the County Council
solution was that we should stump up the
total cost not them you know that was
not again very acceptable but there we
go
right I thought I'd deal with that point
counselor Barnes I've been to scrutiny a
number of times I've got one or two
places that have now I've got a bit of a
speed but it doesn't look as though like
we said it's all skipped the whole area
so as far as I'm concerned you last week
they didn't turn over and that appears
to be just you know the way it is no
criticism anybody bit a lot of farmers
who trying to do our Bursa guy they need
something and they come on average
council riches yeah I'm so just
listening to councillor kettles comments
there and the issue is is engineering
and I know you'll relate to this one in
so much that digging up a road to
running fibre cable is extremely
expensive and and to give you some
context professionally I'm involved with
my business does this kind of
installation for corporate so not for
residential but I understand other
technology works we traverse three
kilometres the other day in the morning
with less than two thousand pounds worth
of equipment so you know if you imagine
two kilometres through an industrial
area what that would cost you to dig it
up and run a cable in and we get
precisely the same speed between those
two points
so engineer the technology has changed
dramatically I think you're absolutely
right there are opportunities
potentially for farmers who want to put
to erect the the stations in their
fields at the top of hills it's a fun
plastic idea already housing the states
like I say they've got the receivers
propped up at the end so I think this is
exciting time for us because we're
actually committing a not insignificant
amount of money in the context of this
technology to brand-new technology that
really will help in rural areas the
reality is we will never get the same
sort of coverage through the road system
as Coventry City as as Warrick district
they're simply we're much more rural
there's much more green space in my ward
there's often a hundred houses they
can't get high-speed broadband at all
there's no intention to run it down the
road because it would cost hundreds of
thousands of pounds to do so this
presents an opportunity for all hundred
houses to get high-speed broadband very
low cost casa riches and once again I
find myself in complete agreement with
councillor Ritchie's what I would say to
councilor kettle is that my
understanding is OSE are expecting a
report on the quality of service
delivered by BD UK imminently I would
suggest that once OSC have that they
then make a recommendation to cabinet to
consider an appropriate recommendation
to cabinet to consider any action that
we might need to take we've requested
the information in the first week of
January which is normal operational
information producer touch the button
they are struggling six weeks later to
produce anything and all we're asking
for is basic coverage information which
they have been unable to provide so
we're not looking for we're not looking
to provide a recommendation it's it's
purely how can they put demonstrated
that what they've said they're going to
do they are going to do and I don't
believe they can do that
chairman Biddy UK or the County Council
were required to come back to the OSC
last Wednesday with some responses to
questions that were put they didn't they
weren't expected to turn up council once
I expected though at least have produced
a schedule of responses to the questions
that were tabled at the previous OSC
I followed that up since Wednesday's I
would say back to the office at the
county council I haven't had a response
as yet I always going to give them a
week and then escalate the matter with
the County Council with the okay
any further debate or discussion right
then so the the proposal to put money
into the broadband not be the UK broad
can propose this to have a pool of
60,000 pounds fifty right a pool of
fifty thousand come mr. Buckland he's
going to produce like a rabbit and a hat
a piece of paper an amazing-looking 1650
and the piece of paper that he's going
to produce suggests that we haven't
actually agreed yet Caroline but we're
close I think we should so basically I'm
going to ask you to vote a moment an
amendment to the papers that were
circulated that replaces the papers that
were circulated and this has the two
proposals that have been supported
preparation for CP Oh Priory squared
Studley fifty thousand and rural
broadband feasibility fund fifty
thousand under the head of our seats in
revenues
and so that is a change and that will
change the medium term financial plan
because it'll clearly make a hundred
thousand two watts of fifty thousand
will make a hundred thousand pound
difference to our balances going forward
but had been on the paperwork what I
think I forgot to draw your attention to
was the business rate retention having
gone up since the draft budget but we
nobody's queried that so we won't worry
about that would just believe that the
figures that have been put in by mister
boland are indeed correct and relevant
right so what I'm going to say is
Council approves the medium term capital
fees and charges are done by cabinet the
medium term financial plan
recommendations three I'm talking about
is as per the piece of paper that has
just been circulated right with those
two amendments proposed we haven't voted
on the amendments yet Peter so we're
still on the amendments so for precision
before I'm told off let us therefore
would not go to the recommendations on
page whatever it is on the cabinet paper
because my pages aren't numbered some it
went wrong there that's the two
amendments 50,000 for priori square
suddenly 50,000 for the rural broadband
feasibility fund these are to be
incorporated into the revenue budget and
therefore into the medium term financial
plan is that agreed well that's sounded
to be a half-hearted thank you right
sound as if you mean it especially the
people that proposed it as sat there
silent
stop making pathetic excuses that's all
right then
I think we'd assumed that by now right
so we've now dealt with the amendments
councillor Morse I'm now going on to the
main recommendation is there something
else you wish to say oh dear
very briefly Trevor Dan you mentioned in
your introduction the conservative
budget proposals and they they've been
judged sound you forgot to mention
proposals have also been found sound I'm
sure you apologized it was an oversight
I'm sure it was chairman doe problems
and can I just mention the reserve
position chairman because on the papers
we just had circulated now we have in
the year 2000 and 1920 we have ten point
eight million of general revenue
reserves on top of that we have another
two million pounds of earmarked reserve
so we've got total reserves at twelve
point eight million pounds against
spending forecast of fourteen point four
million chairman it's something like 89
or 90 percent of one year spending is
being held in reserve and those twelve
point eight reserves are sorry the ten
point eight reserves compared with the
two million that mr. Buckley regards is
the minimum that we should be holding I
wonder if the company could explain to
residents and to the Herald why you
think it is better to hold residents
money in the capsules bank account
rather than let residents keep their
money in their own bank accounts right I
will attempt to answer that question in
the same way as I usually do every other
time you've asked me this question
counselor moss in the last 13 years okay
we all know that in two years time rate
support grant revenue support grant will
do
Sapir and the new homes bonus income is
lighter disappear and the business rates
whatever they call it will be reset and
therefore there's going to be a huge
drop in income and therefore then we
will be setting budgets which eat into
those reserves unless of course we want
to appear not very much stable not very
much in control of our financial affairs
so consequently what we've done is we've
built up a period of time where we do
have a five-year forecast and overall as
you see on the same document from which
you've just quoted that's the end thank
you 5.4 million which I agree is still
in excess of mr. Buckland's prudent
estimate minimum what is also happening
within this council is that we're being
suggested that we can do what the peer
review told us to do and that is looking
at some of our surplus imp of cash and
look at one-off cost which will help us
for when we do fall over the cliff
when there is no possibility under
present arrangements for sending
anything other than a deficit budget we
won't set a deficit budget because we'll
have taken steps and there are examples
of how we can actually spend some of
that money we're not ready to present
them today we're unlikely to be ready to
present them for counseled in two weeks
time when we approve the budget what we
are gonna do is actually look at
something perhaps in the March cabinet
meeting for reference to the April
council meeting about looking at a
certain one-off projects which actually
might make life a bit easier in the long
term and we could of diff
the priority square suddenly into that
list but we decided to actually that was
important enough to bring forward today
because despite the positive news that
we got from the coop at a meeting this
morning it is a bit of we've heard that
before
so we therefore felt that the threat of
CP o should hang over the coop to
actually try and oblige them to do
something
Sonia helm we have a situation whereby
some of that will be proposed to suspend
outside the budget framework what we've
done is looked at our mainstream work to
produce the papers that you have today
and the most important thing is we need
that cushion to make certain that should
our external funding dry out more
rapidly than that we expect we're not
going to have any embarrassing positions
like sort of what could we do to say
bunny must be circulated with your
attention to look at ways of spending
some of these which I'm not saying that
all wisdom isn't contained around this
table I'm sure it is Jim but it just
made me that some other councillors I've
got ideas that they would like to put
forward and I think it would be helpful
if they knew that's perfectly acceptable
but I expected you to ask me this
question of the budget meeting in two
weeks time and I've just practiced my
speech and my reply that I'm gonna give
time shoot with both repeat ourselves
Jalen so consequently I'm imagining that
effectively that all members of the
council will it will effectively hear
that statement get that information
right are we ready to vote then so the
main recommendations as amended
I'll take them on block all five of them
four of which will go to council right
okay
I'm corrected by mr. Buckland number
four doesn't go to full council and
however we have to inform the government
or somehow they have to find out that
we've agreed it so items one two and
five go to full council three and four
now one three and five yes two and four
are resolved here this afternoon is that
all agreed agreed agreed
thank you I heard you that time well
that's everybody except council riches
he mumbled
right so that's the budget
well we haven't finally dealt with it
we've got to deal with it on the 26
right the next item is item six treasury
management strategy statement and
counselor or gun will be the one to
present how can I stop me I wasn't gonna
forget it totally I just thought they're
in a different order right we have here
two supplementary documents
and these are referred to in the very
brief report that mr. Harris has written
to us for us but effectively that's no
criticism for the simple reason that
these documents as they have evolved
have been before us before like other
areas where you've got a substantial
development and you've not only got a
3,000 nod house development at Long
Marston you've also got a Garden Village
I was at the District Council's Network
conference last week and was quite
humbled on Friday morning because there
was a workshop you have choices of which
workshop to go to and I went to the one
on Garden villages and what did they
tell us about what were the two garden
centers that were actually put forward
what was bister which is much larger
than Long Marston and the other one was
Didcot both towns in Oxfordshire and
effectively I was about to feel that
where ours was a lot smaller a lot more
subtle I didn't learn anything about
they're supplementary planning documents
I learned something about their overall
schemes and it was it was quite
interesting to sit and watch some of the
problems that they have when they're
trying to develop them like delivering
infrastructure but with a settlement
like Long Marston we can put so much in
our core strategy but it needs some
details about some of the subtleties of
what to do so we do an SPD a
supplementary planning document which
has the advantage that we can approve it
without an examination in public but
effectively we can effectively get the
council to agree to rules that will need
to be taken account of when you
determine
planning application and planning
applications are already in for Long
Marston I'm not quite sure just where we
are with everything we have a dedicated
office until Hampstead that seems to be
working on this and nothing else but
indeed they can ensure that effectively
we do get a decent settlement what was
important about the garden for this use
is that they represent an opportunity to
provide good design and coming up fairly
soon will be the most job gone on there
is what's the big document that you're
in the process of circulating
development requirements DPD isn't it
right thank you just looking at you I
remember what the title was must have it
written on your face and that will
contain a lot of small detail about
general issues that aren't in the core
strategy but will apply to all planning
applications or certain other selected
planning applications that again is
another document that we will approve or
the council will approve eventually this
document here as you can see is version
point nine it's been through several
iterations some of which have been
before members and you have a tract
version here and I think it's the tract
version or the version of me which is
the version that is that was seen before
with some changes because we've just had
a public consultation and the majority
of changes here are as a result of that
public consultation there's been one or
two other changes that I've asked for
when I have scrutinized it and we also
have a policy Advisory Group l pag there
are one or two changes that have
about through recommendations for which
elpac has considered so we think with
all that screw to their member
involvement that you'll be happy to sign
this off as it stands and that's
precisely what I'm about to ask you to
do coupled up with the different the DPD
SPD is a strategic environmental
assessment steering with quite a beast
but we should becoming familiar with
these if not from infusion but these are
effectively the environmental screening
looking at the effects of these
proposals on the finished product which
are hopefully going to do something for
good by having an environmental
assessment we end up producing a
development that is environmentally
friendly and indeed is not going to add
to our carbon footprint or pollution or
whatever so that effectively is a must
that we've had done it's not up for
debate
it is a professional document but it's
before us to illustrate and demonstrate
that we're safe to approve this because
without the sub the strategic
environmental assessment screening we
wouldn't be safe to deal with this so
any questions councillor fragile ii is
actually the was a thirty million that's
just recently being won from the
government does this mean going forward
will be able to be assured that we're
going to get the affordable housing up
to the quota that we would want plus the
housing mix that we would want because
obviously that didn't happen with the
442 with some disappointment so are we
assured that the new development will
actually give all that this district
actually aspires to for the resident
cancer issues through the as as i'm sure
you well known having
unless they're in Britain a lot of this
information discussed there through the
planning process the applicants have
submitted evidence to support a lower
level of affordable housing we have
appointed appropriate consultants to
consider that evidence and give us a
report as to whether they think it's
appropriate or not they are well aware
that we have been awarded thirteen point
four eight million in support of this
this scheme and are considering that as
part of that so once we have that
consultation report we'll know more my
starting point and I think the the
council starting point will always be
thirty five percent for I might add
another one of my sergeants to London we
met with a client's MP at a conference I
went to he's the chair of the Select
Committee for Communities and Local
Government as it was the date we went to
that particular amazing it's now the
ministry of housing communities and
local government and as a consequence he
was quite emphatic that he that there is
gonna be some changes in to the
viability rules now what he told us back
in November when mr. Webb and I went to
that conference was he that comes
through modifications to the NPP f I had
a document circulated last week from
Steve Quartermaine whose CEO G's chief
planner and he's sort of said expect a
draft modification to the NPP F before
Easter he didn't say how long before
Easter right and I better be careful
what I say about a government because
the press are in the room and paying
attention to my every word so
consequently oh it could be you know on
Easter Saturday about seven o'clock in
the evening you never quite know but we
are on the lookout for the
mtbf when we are promised that the
viability rules will effectively make
developers reducing their demand on
affordable housing different because we
do need those houses we've got a waiting
list this long and we need those we've
got existing houses that they can use
but we also need some new ones that we
can deal with comments were made there
about people moving in about housing mix
that the work the wall and the two
bedrooms of mostly it's the three
particularly the four bedrooms so it's
another sort of concern that we do make
sure in a new settlement we've got a
range of housing mix there but as far as
my master is concerned and that's the
topic of debates at the moment we'll
have to look at the planning
applications when they arrive okay and
assess that but don't forget there is a
notice of motion in were you not a
signatory to that yeah but the
effectively is under consideration and
we've starting to look into it and I
sent a note to mr. weeks a week or two
back seeking some information on the
extent to which that's been happening
I'm still waiting for him to respond to
me but that's not a complaint right I
believed him when he said it was work
underway and will be with me as soon as
possible so we are looking at that
because again if you get the wrong
housing mix again
the trouble is planners they look at the
individual application and sometimes
when we're thinking of these things
going wrong we're looking at the bigger
picture and you know we have to get the
balance right right councillor kettle
Thank You mr. chairman
as you know
plumbers cabinet made neighbors you will
know I was very heavily involved in
reviewing a feasibility study carried
out 495 home application weather
development were indeed received 35
percent approval as outline and reduce
that seventeen and a half
subsequently increased it by one and a
half percent to nineteen that was that
document reviewed
strangely twice because a developer was
not comfortable with the first review
that the professional is appointed by
this counts holding the conclusion they
came up to sorry sir I was just
wondering what this had to do with long
master their speedy castle I'll come to
it in just a second I'll Ryland the
second review was carried out by a
consultant whose appointment was agreed
with developer and the terms of
reference for that review were three
lines of an email there was no formal
letter there were no specific directions
as to what errors who want to look at
and it was a very complex site and I
think at the end of the day it comes
with Hema doesn't help me we carried out
a lot of time on it push the developer
very hard and increased it to about 25%
the point being though they appoint the
the specialist we appointed was not
given detailed instructions by this
council as to what work they should be
carried out now as many people who here
who've worked with professionals you
normally have a letter of engagement
from maybe three four five six pages
long
specifically setting out what work is
required than the three male three nine
email is a little bit less than that
so when counselor riches recharge sorry
says we have appointed a specialist to
review it are we as a council
absolutely convinced that that firm
whoever they may be has a very clear
understand
from this council and we understand what
what they're going to do what report
could have produced so we're trying a
bit so that we're clear I'm entirely
satisfied that direct instructions were
given to the consultants in an
appropriate way through our planning
team the directions were reviewed by
myself and by councilor Pemberton prior
to being submitted with the experience
councilor Pemberton Scot I would expect
him to have brought up any issues
through that something that may have
arisen with your involvement so I'm
entirely happy that has been the case if
if if I don't know when yours went
through if for any reason when this
report comes back it isn't adequate
always missing anything that will be
submitted back to the consultants and
we're sure they do it's quite critical
as to whether it's before I don't know
when you carried out your review council
careful if you will share that with me
now mr. weeks would you like to come in
Jared thank you um I can confirm that
the instructions that council Richards
and Darrin Pemberton cleared were
cleared after you'd started your
scrutiny of the Harper site so the one
did inform the thinking of the other
right okay now we have straight up in
questions about long masks and
councillor bars the point really is that
we have an application at the moment
with no affordable homes and and the
wrong method of birth dispensation in
the respect of five four and two bedroom
at ease I think we would like to think
that we are going to get the right
product in the end in this far village
which we everybody support and not have
to keep fighting all the time
because we do need affordable homes we
do need two bedroom flats and we do need
four bedroom as well
on the record counselor bounce counselor
pen burns and I were given a briefing on
this issue by Neil Hempstead or a few
weeks ago now and our advice to him was
if that's how it stays you know that
there are two ways an application it
doesn't have to be granted indeed can I
assure you that counselor Pemberton's
who's not here he's in the building is
he what are you done with him pursuing
something in connection with your
earlier meeting yeah my apologies which
is why I was too loud the other the
other thing is then it has been The
Parent Council at long last no hear the
area of the bran field site of the
airfield seems to be extended at once or
twice we have mentioned it to meetings
as part of great concern and there is a
thing that a rich by G T's but 21:32 is
well its rate on the the outside for and
flora but we are concerned that it
doesn't get any further than the marsh
bomb Brooke to make sure the other some
things have and some things happened so
what we don't want is to increase the
fund the village as it is to the village
of Long Marston and we have mentioned
this a couple of times and I do know the
parish council over here today are
concerned about it well my recollection
of the boundary that's in this document
I think you were there at the time well
whenever wherever I was my recollection
of the boundary in this document is it
does coincide with the allocated site in
the core strategy a mr. cave is nodding
and now in one place that does go on the
low mast and village side of the Bund
doesn't
and indeed I can remember at the
consultation we had in this room just
before Christmas that was referred to
but effectively that is we don't have a
planning application for that bit of the
site at the moment to my knowledge I'm
looking at mr. weeks now he can
contradict me if he wishes but so
consequently we do have a situation
where by the supplementary planning
guidance does cover the whole site that
will be become developed now we can't
sort of suddenly start bringing our
obscure other sites just because they
happen to be close to Long Marston and
you represent them and you need the
brownie points but you know we can't
actually keep looking at it I think
we've got to accept is this document the
correct framework to govern development
on that site or is it not it is if the
parameters are correct and the
affordable own right well the affordable
homes are in the core strategy council
Rich's I seem to remember something
about this coming up at l-pad where
there is a field or a patch of land to
the west of the Greenway yeah there was
a question mark that we had clarified to
l-pad that that was not intended for
development nothing west of it with the
Greenway was intended for development
which should should clarify your point
the second bit on affordable housing and
portfolio holder for infrastructure is
just confirmed that he doesn't want to
move off 35% call strategy firmly
confirmed 35% and the Chairman has just
confirmed that this lightly revision in
the MPF which might further support that
through the viability issues that we
have this council doesn't budge very
often on that very 5% there's a little
bit of arm-twisting that goes on from a
lot higher place through viability that
that changes that position right then
I'm gonna meet Peter John careful can
you come in and help out here please
Thank You chairman just so there's
there's no confusion at all the the site
area that's in covered by the SPD is
consistent with the site area and the
adopted core strategy members can see it
does extend west of the Greenway but
that's the agreed site area in the core
strategy the SPD then clarifies what
that land will be used for and members
if we can just take you to page 21 of
the track changes version you're patient
so a page 15 of the actual document it's
got to pay journalism you'll see a
number of bullet points then bullet
point eight land west the Greenway will
only be used for open space and planting
so hope that clarifies the situation
okay right well there's no other debates
or comment I will move counselor careful
it's gonna spoil that one day ambition
two points and they were points which
the chairman of the USC suggested I
bring them up today because he was as
you know not here
yes which just just sorry off you say
amendments were made to the SPD although
three paragraphs three point three or
mr. Harris's report says there were no
significant amendments proposed and that
leads us back into the question that
came up the USC was in view of the very
significant concerns raised 18 months
ago relating to the GA
SPD have those lessons being learned to
ensure that the local public feel here
that there has been full and proper
consultation and that there has not been
the misunderstandings that arose
previously in relation to the rather
infamous GLH steering group which of
course there were no minutes or genders
when they are published I be assured
that hasn't happened in this case Thank
You mr. Harris frustrating sunlight on
that one
well I think the key point to say is
that's a very rigorous assessment of all
the comments that were submitted as part
of the draft SPD consultation that's
before you today and it was before L
pack that it's meeting a couple of weeks
ago when I described the changes as
being not significant I guess it could
be for others to judge whether their
significance or not but you will see by
looking through the track changes
versions the the number of changes that
have been made mostly because of the
consultation process and the comments
that people made during that stage thank
you
right councillor Richard Richards and
I'll just throw a 30 Ritchie's to your
point about the steering group yes those
minutes are taken it made a very clear
point that we wanted to have as many of
the members affected or their areas
affected they were involved in that
steering group they are on that and have
a an active input into that steering
group all the minutes are taken and all
of them are published on our long Martin
field web page which includes other
assessments including their assessments
over the road
good luck mr. kair fir'd Thank You
chairman just to follow on from
councillor Richards comment there the
appendix to to this report is the
consultation statement and it does set
out the what consultations been
undertaken and you've got some minutes
from the steering group there as well so
everything everything's in the public
domain that should be we also held
number of consultation events with local
parish councils as well and a local
action group and so I think the
engagement in this in this SPD has been
as required thank you right let's move
on I'm prompted by mr. Buckland for
failing to draw your attention to
appendices two and three I refer to
appendix one this particular document
and tacked on the end of it is a
consultation statement and an equality
impact assessment now we know how well
equality impact assessments makes really
reading but I need to draw attention to
them and the options in Section five one
and two we are the recommend to council
that the SPD is adopted incorporating
the proposed amendments which I'm
proposing or we can rest request further
amendments so the recommendation to
council is manifested option one to
approve the changes identified in the
report and formally adopt the law Marcin
airfield garden village
master plan supplementary planning your
document is that agree agree thank you
now we can move on to the treasury
management strategies statement
unfortunately counsel organ is not with
us today she is on a maintain a mission
with her partner who's been recuperating
from some nasty disease and he's fit
enough to travel so I've approved them
to go somewhere in Spain don't think
anywhere particular for any length of
time they're touring around a bit so
consequently what we have with the
treasury management says a statement
there's something if you remember we
used to have a genielle out here as a
councillor used to do these and she used
to say well it is what it is and
effectively it's a statement which does
exactly what it says in the
recommendations we have from time to
time to refresh and renew our borrowing
limits overall and short-term and the
maximum proportion of interest on
borrowing subject the variable rates is
100% we have to set right and in
relation to the minimum revenue
permission we've got those in Section
2.7 which we're asked to approve and the
annual investment strategy is set out in
Section 4 as Appendix 1 also be approved
any comments for those recommendations
agreed agreed
thank you right call you all do in
unanimity so moving on
Prudential indicators likewise the
Prudential indicators are in that the
report and they actually relates to the
way we administer any borrowing and
indeed they are landmarks and yardsticks
and whatever else so eventually we
really go to the top of page one one
five net financing agreed for the year
zero zero zero zero zero so this is a
report about saying how we don't need to
borrow anything so the indicators
contain with the report are they
approved they're the ones that actually
give rise to that particular spendthrift
way so degrees community infrastructure
levy oh this is me again but I didn't
have my rest then we've adopted SIL
we're collecting it as from the first of
February I don't know that we've had
enough to set the world alight yet in
income because mister weeks
ticked all of the applicants off and
they got their applications in so they
didn't have to be didn't have to suffer
so what we have here is a question on
how do we actually distribute the cash
and you'll see if you read the report
we've come forward with a bidding scheme
those that want the money can bid for it
except for parish councils that get it
automatically I'm slightly worried about
how a parish councils are going to
choose to spend theirs but no doubt
we'll see that in the fullness of time
now basically we have a statement here
of various infrastructure projects that
we've looked at none of those is going
to receive any of that money unless a
responsible body for producing it
actually bids the bidding process is
open to anybody that feels they're going
to provide an infrastructure one of the
things I must make clear from the stars
we are expecting Warwickshire County
Council to also bid for funding for
highways projects that's their principal
work and they will still be entitled to
do what is known as section 38
agreements and get money off developers
independently for that sort of
infrastructure that goes into an S 38
agreement though a lot of it's about the
quality of the tarmac they use so the
roads can be adopted eventually so the
fact that that's put in a list here is
only notional there is no agreement to
actually sort of spend that amount of
money except I notice on page three of
five the cqt two proposal a3 400
Birmingham Road there is an estimate
there of six million and it says in the
notes revised cost was 1.7 million now
that one slip through bearing in mind
that the County Council have already
said that they've got a certain amount
of money they're going to allocate to
Birmingham Road we'll have to wait and
see but there's no agreement to spend a
penny of that unless the County Council
indeed put in a bid then there are
arrangements of for when this money
should be
made out especially to parish councils
who get an automatic block grant on
developments within their boundaries and
you'll see that there are two dates a
year in which the money will be paid
across two parishes quite what mr.
Buckland will do with the money in the
meantime I don't know mister now account
it'll rest in our account until we have
to so anyhow so those are the
arrangements you want to add something
to what I've said oh yeah thank you
later yeah I just want to bring cameras
attention to two minor lemons we need to
make the text with on page 30 and page
127 under paragraph 1 point 2 the third
bullet point says off the 95 percent
either 15 or 25 percent these are
catered pouches
well actually it's 15 or 25 percent of
the quantities for our of the hundred
percent so we need to delete the first
of the of the 95 percent and then on
page 130 well we're talking about how
the proposals and the decision making
process for the proposals 5.1 suggests
that the cabinet will make the decision
and make recommendations to full council
actually it will be the cabinet that
will resolve on the spending on the
bidding process at that point the
quantum of resource will be determined
by how much money was played by cell and
cabinet will be free to make this
pending decision so we will seeking to
change it so that we've got a full stop
after the word decision and remove the
word in and recommendation to full
council yes sorry leader and then that
follows into the necks of deleting the
next sentence reference to council a
right I thank your changes
right councilor moss Thank You chairman
two clarifications if I made one on page
129 paragraph four point one where the
clearly the intention is that each
community gets one grant for bidding
round and the story rich pleasure so
page 129 point four point one well says
the fourth line ward councillors will be
able to make one funding bid for s the
FE C funds on behalf of their committee
the funding round Stratford is carried
by one parish cannot assumed that all
nine councillors in Stratford will be
able to put in individual bits for money
and we're not just talking one bid for
that parish well it depends because
something in Overson could be supported
by the ward member for Overson for
example they wouldn't need to worry
about say bishop term would they you
aren't prepared to take nine bits is
what I'm asking chairman if it's a fool
if we discipline cancer which is not in
yes second clarification Jim six six
point one the council will ensure timely
release of funds when invoices are
received completed works many of these
works take some considerable time and
the people doing the work are not
necessarily going to be in a position to
fund things and do we have a scheme for
part payment on interim invoices in mind
well chairman I mean at the moment this
is similar wording to what we have in
place for the station one of suits
contributions and if the County Council
for instance is the body they won't have
a a cash flow problem we have made
exceptions to a policy in the past where
there have been exceptional
circumstances which mean that the body
making the bid haven't got the
wherewithal to make those payments
upfront so we would kill to be flexible
with the policy council kettle I'm good
to refer back to paragraph 4.1 again
actually mr. chairman with a slightly
different pat on world council's belt
one funny bit on behalf of their
community but for those of us
particularly in rural woods we have a
number of different communities we
represent some of which have no
synergies with each other whatsoever and
may have what is similar planning
applications running at the same time
which have no connection at all both
which might be delivering sole monies
into Stratford thank you mr. Chung could
if a ward number is only allowed one bid
per funding round that may restrict his
ability or her ability to represent
other diverse members of their community
or multiple communities but there will
be multiple opportunities over a period
of time to represent each of the
parishes in a ward
so we will have to rank each parish in
order rather than which could be an
interesting we're not going to have fast
sums of money that he depends on I mean
not every parish will have a project
that will qualifies to be paid for from
sell does it no I'm just saying we might
be in that situation
and if there were two completely
judgment projects in completely at
different ends of the world why could we
not put em there only so six of us we're
not going to putting in twenty each or
something but there may be an occasion
when it is completely appropriate to
submit requests which may in fact be
related in some way or may not be
related what you're saying though is
that you want equal chance to represent
each of your parishes anyone bidding
around if there is an appropriate scheme
then that scheme should be allowed to
stand on its own merits and be
considered by cabinet accordingly
councillor Richards but I think it's
gonna be a similar process the way in
which county councillors distribute
their annual grants that you will have
to represent each of your parishes and
prioritize the ones that you think most
appropriate you I have absolutely no
doubt the you represent you all remember
your residents in an exceptional manner
and I'm sure they will respect your
decision groups when you come to that
and prioritize them in the right way but
you all have an opportunity every six
months for a bit forward if you have
additional ones I'm quite happy to
listen to them
I see infrastructure portfolio holder
and if there are surface funds or funds
are available I can consider those and
put them forward yeah thank you for that
as worded though the document and you
may change portfolios at some point in
the future and your successive may not
have heard your wit wise words the
wording as it sounds at the moment
restricts one claim and I'm sorry it's
very different for County Council fund
county councillors are given that money
themselves which they can then determine
this is a district wide round funded by
applications across the district and it
is not something which is in our own
remit to do and there are some money
maybe significantly greater that I just
like to make that comment so I've got
one more point five point one which
you've made an amendment to the decision
will be made by cabinet presumably that
will be subject to call in as it's not
going to counsel by OSC after that
decision is or it's not late oh the
world is full of various decisions and
cabinet decisions are known as executive
decisions that's a statement in the law
and indeed those decisions are the ones
that are subject to calling so if we
merely add to the repertoire of cabinet
work they still get the exactly the same
treatment of those that have been there
for a long time
Thank You mr. moon clearly for
clarification on that point but I would
like confer the consideration of my
first point what haven't we answered in
your first point by our let me counselor
it is coming probably can be some of
some help here because um while I
understand both points to the right I
actually think that this couldn't have
been worded any better which is unusual
for me normally I can pick holes in in
wording because if this says it can also
be made by stratford-on-avon district
ward councillors on behalf of their
communities what it doesn't say is on
behalf of their ward and it doesn't say
on behalf of a parish this is on behalf
of their communities so I have three
parishes in my community in my ward I
could consider all of those three
parishes to be a part of the community
if the project warranted it so I think
the wording is actually really good yeah
Stockton's enough to and don't have that
much but they may do if if somebody
suddenly decided to put thousands of
houses on south and cement works then
then they may well be included included
in a bid because they're part of the
wider community so I think he's worried
it really well and I just hope that that
in which location I think there is
enough clarity because council riches
and I have read it differently may be
the correct wording is to change their
community to their communities and
thereby identifying different
communities within the ward
well we are talking about collective
ward members aren't we really I mean
somebody like I saw a Miss John Thank
You chair and I mean the the background
to is that we just need to ensure the
process is manageable and so
I don't have a strong view either way
it's really to help to give more members
a leadership role I think the point I
would make though is we need to be
realistic about the amount of funding we
will get through SIL the parishes will
get the 15% capped or the 25% if they've
got named the plan made automatically
and I would urge in hope that sort of
local organizations go to the parishes
in the first instance this is if you
like an additional way to to perhaps
spend some money I think the the
priority for the district council will
very much be District Council needs so I
wouldn't want so there's been no answer
I wouldn't want to perhaps give false
hope or expectation that they are with
numerous beads that there might be more
successful that's otherwise so
what do we want to do 4.1 walk
counselors will able to make one funding
bid on behalf of their community funding
round actually it's gonna be two funding
rounds a year so they can come back
every six months chairman if I may yes
and we discussed I think the
practicality of that is of the second
funding round certainly would be
optional so there's only been at least
one per annum possibly two I think there
was a bit more certainty plan than that
John however depends if we spent it all
in the first round yeah right who wants
to speak from over here I've got faces
looking at me no right so do we want to
make a change to that community
communities anything I missed mr.
Buckland right the recommendations are
to endorse the spending arrangements
attached as Appendix two including into
updating the infrastructure delivery
plan yes by a few typos okay is that
agreed right can I have a rest from
presenting please it might not be your
job
oh it is I've already lined out Kristen
you are annoying these arrangements for
properties uses temporary accommodation
councillor Richards thank you and simin
so members this report has been brought
to you as a result of an existing lease
that expires in March this year you'll
know we have a tripod agreement
tripartite agreement between orbit
ourselves and chapter one
garetty limited who currently manage
there 23 properties that we have for
temporary accommodation across the
district when that ins expires in march
orbit have requested that we become the
head lessee on those properties and then
we will we as the council will tender
which we've already begun will attend it
for a provider to manage those
properties on our behalf so ultimately
we end up in a similar position only
we've become the the head of the lease
which gives us more flexibility over the
number of properties we've got within
the agreement we are able to extend the
number of properties we've got up to 32
and we can do that in a relatively short
timeframe we can also reduce the number
that we have based on requirements there
is a risk to this and that is it's the
tune of the value of the the lease which
is a hundred and thirty three thousand
because we have begun the tender process
already and we have a provider already
lined up we expect this to be a nil cost
to the council if for any reason the the
provider ceases to be that provider
there will be a cost to the council it
still allows us the freedom and
flexibility to maintain those temporary
accommodations and we can immediately
appoint a new a new provider if require
as and when required and so members the
recommendations are that we do enter
into this agreement to lease the
properties for a period of six years and
that a suitable provider be appointed by
the District Council to enter into a
minor agreement with that third party
thank you and for clarity this is for an
increased number of this this will
maintain minutes we have an obligation
to house people and this will maintain
the properties we currently have it does
that the agreement does give a scope to
extend the number of properties if
required but at the moment the plans to
maintain it right okay so we're not
gonna reduce them
we're just gonna manage the existing
stock a different way hey sorry yes
counseling so they're owned by orbit
that's why we're leasing them right
shall we no debate go to the
recommendation centers the portfolio
holder proposed that we leased
properties for further six years and
provide a suitable provider for managing
them it's not agreed right moving on to
item 10 options evaluation provision of
stratford-on-avon District Council owned
as supported temporary accommodation
scheme I'm glad you introduced it
counselor st. so members again this is
them this has come forward as part of
the work of the affordable housing
working group we set up a subgroup of
that committee to consider ways in which
we can provide temporary accommodation
particularly for homeless people in the
district and recommendation one in this
instance has more or less been covered
by the the agreement we've made
previously but to give you a bit more
background to what's being presented
here the subgroup were considering a
number of objectives and a number of
options in order to provide appropriate
temporary accommodation across the
district the objectives were set as a
four different objective objective ae
was to meet and exceed the minimum legal
requirements in terms of provision of
temporary accommodation I think that's a
given given is a requirement objective B
is through the provision of support
improve the ability of households to
maintain their in independence and
sustained future tenants is build their
capacity and through increased
resilience reduced demand on the wider
public sector objective C to provide a
cost effect
and versatile range of temporary
accommodation options and option D
necessary objective D maintain good
relationships with local landlords both
social and private through the provision
of capable prospective tenants with the
knowledge and skills to maintain future
accommodations so those are the
objectives that we set and the options
that were considered by our subgroup
were one a dispersed share of single
occupancy scheme with floating support
for one 4-bit house and eight two bird
flats including revised empty home
assistance grants option two is to build
a new facility with support on-site
option three to convert an existing
building with support on sites and
option for the purchase of an existing
B&B and provision of support on site
each of those options were considered in
alignment with the objectives that I
previously stated and it was considered
that in the long run option two would be
the most appropriate way forward so
that's option two to build a new
facility with support on-site now very
clearly that takes some time to do so
the proposal that's been put forward by
the affordable housing working group is
that the requirements we have now are
met by our existing provision of
temporary housing temporary
accommodation and alongside that that
our policy team develop and consider a
range of policies and funding options
that would help us deliver on option two
so I will put that to open to debate
Thank You general council ammos we look
at ten point two or ten point two one we
spent half a million pounds last year on
bed and breakfast and
this year we're expecting about 350,000
now assuming that one bed-and-breakfast
tonight is say 50 pounds and probably
quite generous we're talking last year
of 10,000 bed and breakfast nights and
we're talking this year of 7,000 bed and
breakfast nights it seems an
astonishingly high figure to me if
you've got more accurate figures Peter
I'd be very interested in another but I
just wondered if we've got a target for
what we would like to see bed and
breakfast and I like to get down to in
the future
um I don't think we've set specific
target very clearly we want to avoid
that that's why we're undertaking the
work that we are ultimately that what
we're looking to do here is completely
remove the need for bed and breakfasts
so I guess the ultimate target is to
have zero I wouldn't want to put that as
a target for the coming year but
certainly the ultimate target is zero
right no more discussion so the
recommendations this su support option 1
and develop a range of policy and
funding options which will deliver
option do nobody's thought about
supporting and provision of BMV or other
probably immediate places we could buy
in that school right if there's no
further debate I'll take a vote on the
recommendations one the implementation
of option 1 and that depends on the
agreement of the council budget but
we've included the options in those
budget papers so those two things will
go hand in hand and then funding
acquisitions which were the develop
option to write those two
recommendations agreed thank you right
we then move on so I think the items
that are pulled out and nobody's asked
me to pull anything out except I'm going
to pull out the first one the leaders
policy advisory group on the 14th of
December because it says present counsel
at T Jefferson apologies counselor TT
Jefferson so I'm just wondering if he
gave his apologies at the meeting right
there are four reports there those
agreed or we note those let me see a
24th of January mr. chairman you have
included on page 169 Northend which is a
village in my ward a little bit of a
surprise that that's Compton's head up
to clear as I was actually discussing
this morning her
housing numbers in the village with
various different people could you could
use tourism like where northern suddenly
appeared from and is there anything I
should know as the ward number about
this well it's gonna say should have
asked for this to be called out for it
to be debated and hasn't from can give
him a simple answer I have issued a
leaders notice of decision on this
change and therefore that change is
effectively in place so therefore we we
wondered l pag didn't have the authority
to actually really designate it the
leader does have the power to do that
and I have exercised that power
so the dis haven't considered the paper
in relation to land book and whether
that should be declassified as local
service village and that was done so
based upon the the size of the parish
but also the the public transportation
connectivity and it has been downgraded
quite significantly for that book the
bus timetable that was submitted also
included the service which certainly
also serves north end and therefore
consideration was saying well actually
would the same follow for north end so
at this point there's no there's no
there hasn't been downgraded away in any
way in relation to north into the moment
only that it be investigated similar to
lab drug when will a decision on
northern death will be either considered
at all made I'm confused now I thought
we signed this off determine you did in
relation to tonight Brooke yes as a
local service village categorization
counselor kettles talking about the
reference to north end which is in and
that's what I'm sorry I'm looking at
John
right so we need some further
information on North End yes and then we
can make a decision in the same way as
we have a labral okay counselor riches
helps i remember this conversation
specifically when the downgrading was
more of a mathematical equation rather
than a subjective decision made by the
leader it was just the the leader was
present in L pack and had the authority
to carry out that change so far as
policy was presumably some maths it's an
issue of maths not we just think it
should be not a category for LSP anymore
it's just because of this meeting and it
isn't it's in my ward and it happened to
be topical to the sons discussion I had
this morning right I'm going to close
this discussion down down because you
didn't give you notice right sir we do
series that's a mechanism will take
place right any urgent business mr.
Buckland there's none children you've
thrown this note at me here right royal
shuttle verbal update that's long master
their field honey board rail shuttle
again this hasn't been called out so we
shouldn't take it but but I better tell
people now I'm taking this far we're
going to oppose appoint successful
consultants of the work is expected to
commence this week it is hoped that the
final draft report will be available by
8:00 or that's on the rail shuttle might
be fine time to turn up we've been going
for over an hour and a half right if
there's no other business I will close
the meeting